are you enjoying your time without the
breath of the wild running across the
world and finding as many Couric's seeds
as possible well they're sure to get you
more inventory slots but finding every
last one may not be worth it
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
stay up to date on everything Zelda
there are nine hundred Korach seeds in
breadth of the wild and reddit user fate
awaits found all of them only to be
rewarded with something crappy and I
don't mean that figuratively once you
collect all 900 seeds the maracas
shaking has to gives you his gift and
well I'm pretty sure it's his poop it
looks like poop it smells like poop and
the worst part of all it fares a strong
resemblance to khorog seeds I don't mean
to point fingers or anything but I'm
pretty sure those dança rocks were
giving you their poop
you'd think doing all that work would
result in something significant but
unfortunately it seems that the golden
poop items only use is to make has to do
a dance of your choosing and on top of
that the determined reddit user says
they've played breath of the wild for
172 hours
now I like to watch that goofy tree
person shake his maracas but anyone who
worked that hard to get all the seeds is
probably a little upset we'll keep you
updated if anything more significant
comes from the golden poop but for now
check out our video on the nine things
we wish we knew before starting breath
of the wild